good morning it's time for you to see a
day of my life weekend edition look how
i start my day you ready you've come
here
he's literally slapping me with his
tongue can you lay down oh no
um
[Music]
always brush your teeth before you eat
citrusy foods fun fact protects your
enamel
[Music]
who's ready to make some orange ricotta
almond toast i know i am we have the
navel orange with the classic navel on
it we have the caracara orange tara cara
on the right navel on the left toast
bread in toaster or however you prefer
are there other ways to toast spread
the more you can get these important
vital nutrients from whole foods the
better and an orange is a great way to
do that i've been hypnotized
quarter inch slices on this god these
smell so good the citrus just pops i'm
not even terrible at this the beauty
that is oranges all right our toast is
done almond ricotta check you know i
love honey do you love honey speak if
you love honey
do you know that three-quarters of
americans don't get their recommended
fruit intake that's a problem folks that
is a problem
tell me you would not eat that tell me
you wouldn't eat that i'm not to eat it
myself
okay it pops
[Music]
i gotta go to work working weekends is
not always the most pleasant thing but i
think you kind of get used to it
unmentioned benefit of working on a
weekend
no traffic even parking is easier on a
weekend look how empty the parking lot
is good morning jenny oh good morning
are these flowers for me be honest oh
yes they are you're lying beautiful
tulips yeah whose flowers are these
they're bored
who gave them to you
somebody are we seeing patients are we
saving lives jenny yes we are okay today
is interesting in that there's a really
good balance of virtual visits and
in-person appointments and i just did a
virtual appointment with a patient who
i'm checking in with uh regarding their
mental health we've been working on uh
treating their depression their anxiety
pain issues that were going on as a
result of several accidents in their
life the beauty of family medicine is
that we can think holistically so we
look at the whole picture especially as
a doe i just want to show you guys
something cool here here's our lab where
we do some of our work we have the
microscopy here if we're doing any kind
of slides here we have the urine
dipstick test we have our strep test our
pregnancy test basically what happens in
this room is point of care testing
anything that you need to do that can be
done in office happens in that room
we're delivering those results
instantaneously to the patient that
allow us to make on-the-spot clinical
decisions a lot of times you don't need
a lab test in order to get a diagnosis
but sometimes it really helps facilitate
that process and rule conditions out
something else i want to show with you
is that because we're family medicine we
take care of pediatric patients and we
understand the importance of development
and learning how to read and
consistently challenging our brains we
actually have a reach out and read
program where we stock like huge sums of
books here
and basically what we try and do is in
every pediatric appointment is to get a
child set up with at least one new book
so they can continue reading continue
exploring learning about medical
subjects and the beauty is we have them
in multiple languages as well i want to
introduce you to my best friend
the interpretation card well i speak
okay spanish when you get a complaint
like fatigue nausea these really
non-specific symptoms meaning that they
don't tie directly to an illness you
have to ask a lot of questions you have
to get a good understanding of what the
patient is describing the history is
probably the most important aspect
having an in-person translator like this
where they can visualize the patient the
patient can visualize the interpreter it
goes such a long way in helping diagnose
patients it improves quality of care
this is where tech comes in handy this
is how we improve the doctor-patient
relationship instead of harming it
because the doctors that sit there in
the middle of patient visits and just
type the whole time i think that hurts
more than it helps jenny can you imagine
how long we've been working together are
we going to celebrate our 10-year
anniversary journey
do you have fun working with me yes
you're like a little kid yes but that's
not good you don't want a doctor who's a
little kid
i heard you might watch a video or two
really be honest is this guy a good
boyfriend
yeah
well we love him here so we hope you
love him just as much
i love him
i love you bro this is how you know
we're passionate about our health look
at that pull-up bar right in the office
[Music]
guess who's done with their shift and
gets to go home to bear this guy i just
pulled up to my place gonna park up have
a little midday snack and you know these
naval oranges actually contain dietary
fiber which i love because we first of
all under eat fiber generally speaking
dietary fiber can help control appetite
decrease rates of type 2 diabetes
obesity heart disease etc
that's why midday snack right there and
when i arrive home the first person to
greet me is the newfoundland
yeah
all right i think it's time to take out
the new new view ready
he doesn't look ready i like to train
him a little bit before i head outside i
feel like if i do a few exercises with
him to uh reinstill his training he does
better on walks lately this guy's been
slacking
touch
good boy so the idea here is that he
waits no matter how far i go
[Music]
okay come
good boy the only struggle of giving
this guy treats ew you see the drawer
look at the trolls
is it oh what a handsome fella can i
have a paw
good boy nice to meet you can the other
paw
speak good boy okay down
by dead
okay god
[Music]
um so right now i'm gonna head over to
the bank do some errands
he doesn't even run
he just hops around stop peeing on
everything it's such a gorgeous day out
in new york city wow look how good bear
is while i'm at the atm
just waiting for me being a good boy one
of the funniest parts about walking with
bear is that everyone in new york city
loves to scream oh my god look at that
bear and i'm like little did you know
his name is bear after walking bear i
just hopped in a quick shower i'm about
to do a live stream with an awesome
university talk with their
pre-med pre-health society here i'm
really excited my setup is kind of
really messy here but that's okay as
long as the background looks great let's
do it all right late night sessions in
the gym i'm heading back today about to
do some lat pull-downs here you can come
watch this exercise
[Music]
good set high five now it's time to hit
the lower last a little rear deltoid i'm
going to do some low rows
[Music]
the key here is to not rush your reps
post jim having a little oj here
fresh squeezed action it's a full orange
day for me as you can tell and actually
juice post workout not a bad idea high
carb load equals insulin kick it
actually pushes the nutrients back into
your muscles after a hard workout i need
a little replenishment of my glycogen
store so cheers bear what do you think
[Music]
you